mesdames et messieurs bonsoir et bravo
donc à l'équipage de l'airbus d'air
france détourné la nuit dernière entre
nice et le caire un jeune pirate de
l'air égyptien a menacé de tout faire
sauter avec une boîte remplie soi-disant
de tnt en fait c'était une boîte vide
l'équipage n'est pas rester passif il a
profité d'une escale technique à
brindisi en italie pour se débarrasser
du pirate risques calculés mais risque
quand même avec un heureux dénouement
heureux est rapide
voici l'auteur du détournement au moment
de son arrestation à brens d'isis et un
jeune égyptien de 19 ans étudiant au
caire en psychologie qui s'est présenté
au juge d'instruction italiens comme un
pacifiste rêvant de rétablir la paix
entre l'égypte et la libye
un pirate apparemment pas très dense
dangereux qui a surpris utiliser larmes
du bluff une boîte de biscuits vide qui
lisait plein de dynamite une hachette
d'un cent dix prises à bord plus tout de
même un couteau
cela a suffi à impressionner et à faire
tourner en rond pendant six heures au
dessus de la mer année l'airbus de la
ligne paris-le au caire avec 230
passagers à bord le pirate de l'air
voulait aller en libye
mais devant le refus des autorités
libyennes l'avion à court de carburant
devait finalement se poser la brindille
déjà à cause de ses propos incohérents
tenu pendant le voyage devant les
passagers impassible
plus personne à bord ne le prenais
vraiment au sérieux a brandi les doutes
sont devenus certitude au moment où le
jeune étudiant est descendue sur la
piste avec le mécanicien de bord pour
surveiller le plein de kérosène
profitant de cette imprudence et d'une
seconde d'inattention
le mécanicien n'a eu qu'à remonter la
passerelle 4 à 4 et à lui claqué la
porte au nic
il a essayé de re de reprendre la
passerelle de l'avion et avec la hache a
voulu taper dans la porte
il a cassé d'ailleurs un petit bureau un
petit verre mais les économies des
moteurs en route vous avez lu mais tous
les phares ils étaient très
impressionnés par le
pour la manoeuvre il est redescendu en
courant il est parti et il a été cueilli
par la police
sa mise à prix mais pourquoi était-il
descendez vous l'avez d'éjecter réagi à
désirer mais son gré pourquoi parce
qu'il est en confiance il vous avez vous
les accies activer les plats et vous les
surveiller leurs chiots ling et elle est
décernée ce qui prouve qu'il est n était
pas pas très bien organisée sûr que ce
pirate à ce moment-là bluffé absolument
sûr c'est qu'ils ont sur qu'il n'avait
pas de campus en cabine et donner nos
efforts sur que son armement était un
abonnement data poutine avait bien
marché
d'accord nous ont plongés pendant une
bonne heure il était menaçant il était
très menaçant c'est à dire il avait un
couteau sous la gorge des mécaniciens et
un paquet soit disant de d'explosifs
dans sa ceinture
comment vous compte qu'il bluffait pas
son comportement au filet au fil des
heures
c'est à dire par la façon il ne serait
absolument pas les communications
téléphoniques
rader téléphonique il ne se voyait pas
d'indications
il n'était pas au courant de toutes les
choses de connaissances générales
les pirates de l'air ne sais pas s'il ya
des micros par exemple à vous quatre
vous ne pouviez pas le maîtriser
imaginez vous un cockpit avec déjà six
enfants pilotaient de communiquer
attaché voyez est un monsieur derrière
vous des brûlures que vous êtes assis et
un couteau sur la gorge
vous allez vous lever et essayez de vous
débattre il est resté avec ces comprimés
pendant une bonne heure au début août
tout l'art du détournement
quelles étaient ses intentions et j'ai
s'ignorent il ay la ville a fait appel à
un moment au consulat d'égypte qui
aurait voulu il aurait voulu récupérer à
bord ayant mené à une destination
inconnue mais tout ça a été assez
décousu et les ryan très précis tarek el
sayyed est aujourd'hui inculpé de
piraterie aérienne et de séquestration
par le juge italie